Let's refocus here for a moment we are still in domain number 7 which is all about
all of those day-to-day activities that the security function gets into and supports and activates
and does for example and in this section we're going to talk about how companies buy all kinds of things
like hardware and software and security needs to be involved in that process right from the start
and throughout because obviously hardware and software represents value to the organization
and just like any other valuable asset needs to be protected based on that value.
Yeah and one of the really important things that organizations need to do is maintain
asset inventories this is an inventory of everything they have and having been involved in quite a
number of breach responses it's very very common that the way that attackers find a way into an
organization is they find a system that no one's remembered is there anymore no one's thinking
about it and importantly does not have an owner because for every single asset we need to have
an owner who's accountable for the protection of that asset and when you don't have that when no
one knows it's there we know when cares is any security be controls being put in places and when
protecting it patching it configuring it and the answer of course is you know and you know we
learned all about this in domain number 2 that protecting any asset including hardware and software
starts with knowing what you have and capturing that into your inventory and then the next step is
as Rob just mentioned identifying ownership because it's the owners that will start the process
of protecting those assets because they're in the best position to understand value yeah and so
asset inventories you got to create add something as soon as you have it and then evergreen these
things constantly heat them up to date not an easy thing to do no and so that's where we kind of
talk about the asset management life cycle so walk us through this John what are we what are we doing
here yeah and I think we've seen this before I mean when you look at the life cycle of any asset
it you know may start for example at the planning phase you understand that you need something
to address goals and objectives of the organization and you're going to go out there and buy it for
example and so the bottom line here is you don't have to memorize these phases the bottom line is
what we've learned many times and that is security needs to be involved right at the start in the
planning phase in this case so that we can understand the requirements of security and then build
that into as we go through the entire life cycle of in this case any asset we call it asset
management but asset security management needs to be part of that right at the start throughout each
of the phases as we've said and what ties in with this is this concept of configuration management
the idea being the behind configuration management is that when you've bought some new piece of
software new piece of hardware you should never just put it out on the network on the environment
in the default configuration why not not secure oh I mean if the password is root root or you know
what of the default is that's well known by attackers so a huge part of deploying new assets in
the environment is going through configuration management and this is where we've talked about
that concept of hardening a number of times and where you go through when you configure a device
according to a baseline that you've established for that device all the sort of configuration that
needs to be done to make sure that that device is securely configured for your environment
and then you can deploy it into production but you're not done with configuration management yet
there's still the all ongoing I mean when a device is out there if you let's say a 50 web
web servers if you decide to update the configuration of those web servers patch them or something
what you need to make sure you do with all 50 of them make sure they remain in compliance with
that baseline so configuration management covers both the deployment and then ongoing
operations of the system and even the retire the commission phase that is the end